I'm in Canada so I was just in Canada
okay so the last time I worked with
Anthony yeah anyone want to see some
fire no and I interviewed him and the
entire interview he butchered my
Canadian accent and look look look and
two minutes how well you but you can how
great your American accent is no one
drink but your I think all you have is a
in like a boot to think that's pretty
much it that's the whole Canadian if I
don't see you just like this and I'm
like hey sorry
did you hear both the dog that do is
Canadian right sorry I like the way you
say sword I'm sorry Sam sorry okay but
see if I can it say thank you I don't
know how to do the way that you're
talking your way I don't know what I'm
Way more Canadian I'm like shepherd's
pie I like the dance and it is English
right shepherd's I see how they eat it
in Canada I loved the film I love see
you know I loved seeing two latino leads
OC was represented in film like this is
amazing I know that you did like a
physical transformation in the sense
that you got really physical real fit to
don't I don't look I'm not miss Bala
today's like look amazing no no and I
listen and that's not self deprecation I
feel very comfortable in my skin but I
definitely transformed for Miss Bala to
change it up and like then I knew that
Anthony was gonna cut money off of my
waist I was like I gotta be for that
moment rip open assuring she goes think
she fainted what I thought was the most
fun was see me run in heels and I was
thinking how is her feet when she gets
home Oh beat let me tell you I don't
can't feel my big toe if I was anybody
else is that crazy I had to look it up I
thought it was like something was wrong
with me
but like my big toe in them oh my god
girls do things that don't
makes sense what all right like but how
fear said these heels
they're gangster right I mean but the
thing is you're a beautiful girl and you
came outside with your feet wrapped in
Reynolds Wrap you know what to do gonna
say yo that's some sexy pictures yes yes
you - I'm with you on that I'm sure you
don't pay em Tiny's yeah saves more yeah
in this film I mean working on this film
obviously the final for the final season
of jane the virgin and then being
engaged congratulations
how do you plan a wedding or have a
personal life when you're so busy as did
you how life no but you know what I was
a struggling actor for so long and I say
struggling because I was definitely on
couches
I was definitely struggling oh I love
but that's not a bad thing it's good to
struggle you know um but that being said
I didn't eat Jane so I was 29 so I had a
lot of sleep before then a lot of
personal a lot a lot of friendships a
lot of dinners I don't have that so much
anymore but I do have something I've
been working really hard towards so I
try to squeeze them in yeah I get to
work with my friends all right and now
you're losing friends cuz all they want
you to do is pay for dinner like my boys
like yo let's go out get dinner hi yo
I'm like yep we going to Red Lobster
that's what I'm saying we're going out
of garden homey all y'all getting is
bread baskets and salad yeah with a
bread Everlast you order off there all
you can eat buffet I did
and it's not about you HBM diet I'm done
with you today